if you want to take a flight to space
with jeff bezos you can do it for 28
million bucks
is it even worth it by the way to 20
million bucks you know i can mix when we
get to that story i'll tell you what
they're going to do
it's interesting for someone it
definitely is worth 28 million if you're
a billionaire here's a question if
you're worth a billion would you spend
2.8 percent of your what
wealth to go to space if i love you you
would if i loved it that much
space enthusiasm i'm asking you though
would you
do you have any desire to go to space
yeah i'm down
listen when you're that wealthy when
you're in the billionaire club
it's all about clout but what i'm asking
you is at what because to me it's all a
percentage conversation that's all it is
what percentage of your wealth are you
willing to spend
to go into space what percentage yeah
do you know what i'm saying you
understand what i'm asking you like
meaning if you're 280 million dollars
cash would you spend 10
of it if you're a billion dollars would
you spend 2.8 percent of it at
what percentage are you willing to say
10 okay so at 280 you would say yes to
it
i'd say yeah exactly that's interesting
a gambling number
i don't even know if i'd want to go to
space okay so that's the question
whether you'd want to go or not how
about you no desire to go into
race at all but if somebody said hey
would you want to take a private jet
and go to the nba finals the world
series the olympics the super bowl in
one year
i'd do ten percent of space what would
you spend let me ask you a question
folks you're listening to this you're
worth a billion dollars matter of fact
forget about
you're worth a billion dollars would you
spend 28
of your wealth to go into space thumbs
up if you would thumbs down if there's
no way in the world you could care
less about going into space right now
we're at 60 zero let's see what the
ratios are going to be
let me tell you why it's it's a big deal
tell me because you know when you enter
that billionaire class it's all about
clout
i got the richest this i got the biggest
boat i got the fastest car
yeah i got the ducati whatever whatever
it is that you
are chasing with the cloud-chasingness
yeah now you're going to freaking space
bro
what or you could say is that even was
that even a thing ever on anyone's mind
yeah
now you get to go to space even if it's
for 11 minutes apparently
it's overrated it's 11 minutes
are we talking about this story are we
holding it let's go right into it right
now
here's the deal you also could be the
only billionaire to die when your
parachute doesn't open
there's a one percent championship man
up top
please jesus christ you know what it's
season rest time
if we're on this topic wouldn't it be
interesting to know who the guy is they
haven't figured it out yet they haven't
announced it yet so 28 million he paid
in this elect in this auction i say it's
richard branson would that be the
ultimate
publicity stunt ever he hops on board
bezos's ship there's only one bigger
publicity stunt if it's elon musk that
did it
boom we got roommates going on hilarious
you think you think you're beating me to
space because that's the whole thing
in space next thing you know elon shows
up you like speed
i uh i think i would be very curious
to do it um kids are under
10 i'd probably do it if they were above
if the youngest was
above 14 they had plenty of the dad they
need i would probably do that no that's
probably how it works
you're a factor in risk and factoring in
the value of a father figure in a kid's
life
after 14 if i die they got plenty out of
me if they screw up after that's on them
why 14. i think that's a good agent at
that point you're gonna
at that point i listen to your parents
anyways you're gonna do whatever the
hell you want to do so
if i've taught you whatever i taught you
until 14 you want to do whatever you
want to do if it didn't work you know
what my teaching stuff i think i'll move
on
think about it they have hundreds of
hours of your videos yeah to absorb you
the rest of their life
anyway you know but dude hey bazels was
brilliant how he did this because
this capsule is cool two-thirds of it is
windows right so it's all set up for
for future tourism so that's the whole
idea
so so what they're going to do is
they're going to go straight up they're
going to hit a speed of 2 300 miles an
hour which is three times the speed of
sound like that okay so it burns off all
the fuel it can't go any higher
so i think it's about 64 miles up in the
air that's where you kind of enter this
space area
so then they're going to be weightless
then they take off the seat belt they
can float around for about two minutes
and then they can take their pictures
and they're going to look throughout the
windows they're going to see earth
they're going to see the round earth in
the background and then they come down
and then they
they're thrown out with parachutes
that's how they're getting down and
they're going to land in the west texas
desert
20 miles an hour is what they're be
hitting the ground at about with these
parachutes so
you know they've done it many many times
without humans so this is the first time
and by the way nasa
has calculated when you go into space
there's a one percent chance you die
based on how many space flights we've
had and how many people have died in
space so
it's a lot riskier than going up in a
plane it's a total
ego boost for whoever is doing this it
would be cool i guess if you do survive
i just don't have i don't need thrills
i'm i'm not that guy
that's looking to you know go into space
and come on back down
on earth one percent is that bad if it's
one percent i may actually do it today
if it was a one percent chance one
percent
i would do it i would do it if it's one
percent 28 million bucks
yeah yeah it is it is definitely
something on you can you imagine you go
for a job interview so what can you put
us what you have only one thing you've
done in your life tell us about the last
year of your life forget haagen-dazs i
know it's impressive forget burger king
forget about the fact that i was in
morgan stanley military ballets sorry
i went to space with jeff bezos hey
here's the question we should've asked
dropped the mic
customer service head of customer
service that's why you didn't do the
podcast last week because we would have
said
house space which one are you picking i
chose the house
good call as of last week
congratulations i appreciate you know
that you announced that
i'm excited about it for someone that is
not interested in doing space whatsoever
and isn't interested in the thrills
tom zenner certainly knows every
freaking detail of what's going on with
his face
i think deep down inside he wants to go
yeah but i think he's also looking at
he's got kids
and he wants to see what he's doing the
permission slip i want to go to space
shuttle sorry honey
you can't go we're not signing i'm not
going to do it you have to do too much
we have to do dishes this weekend
dictator has that much power she
actually she she's actually
very very powerful okay and you want to
retract that statement or because she's
going to hear it
like five three five she's acting off
she said she's not done growing she's
almost five
she's not done
here's the next question yeah because
obviously there's you said one percent
risk
jeff bezos is going to space with his
brother and whoever this 28 million
dollar
winner of the auction is respect i don't
know who it is they haven't announced it
yet
obviously the the the 99 chance that
everything will be okay let's talk about
that one percent chance how much life
insurance do you think jeff bezos has
how much estate planning
do you think he's done do you think he's
got a billion dollars of life insurance
and nobody gets that much the reason why
i know he doesn't have a billion dollars
of insurance because the record of the
biggest policy sold was 210 million
dollars some number like that that went
to guinness
so but no one knows who the 210 was some
say speculator was bill gates some say
was uh
one of those buffett or bill gates so i
know he doesn't have billion dollars of
insurance
but at this point of the game you know
insurance at that level
yeah you know you're worth a couple
hundred billion dollars his insurance is
he still owns amazon his insurance is
lobbyist his insurance is working with
dc his insurance is washington post
that's his insurance policy
to make sure the estate taxes don't go
against him et cetera et cetera that's
his insurance policy yeah anyway so in
this at this table
you're not going i'm going you would go
i'm in i would go
kai's not going so you guys would run
the podcast we'd be out there hanging
out with jeff
let's see what happens 56 million budget
we could we could raise that kind of
money i got an idea speaking of that 99
one percent i'll put down one percent
down payment you take care of the rest
of the 99 percent of the 28 million your
level we got a deal
we got a deal yeah i got to tell you i
feel like we can meet halfway or
99 or semi genius there's i don't care
what anybody says about you in the
comments section you're you're genius
well here's the problem he gets ten
percent of the parachute right
yeah what i would do we would do the one
person 99 but you get to sit outside so
you get like a
view from the outside it's even better
2500 miles an hour
can you imagine the whole what do you
call it when the lips come back we see
that's like when we were gonna fight
exactly
we lost adam there's a parachute in
space but doesn't mean
in space there's no gravity so he just
keeps going and going and going and also
you
run into a land in a in a
a place where it's like earth and aliens
fall in love with you and
adam becomes the king the ruler of that
planet
yeah i mean sauce yep and he has 90 kids
king sauce
new nickname no more soy boy king sauce
breaks the
community might get upset so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye